what is this
is this a two second podcast
i feel like i'm just going down the
rabbit hole
we swear nothing anand
oh that's how we pronounce
i usually just say vishi
or anand
okay
um i'll insist
okay so for gamma time
for a moment i didn't think we were
going into a stafford but uh
yeah so here there's two moves there
queen d4 and h5
um
i think i'll go for h5
queen d4 i think is objectively best to
win back the pawn
but here
uh
yeah there's a lot of ways like can go
wrong here actually
so
just some review if h3
there's queen d4 if d3 i believe queen
f6 is the best move
if bishop g4 i would take with pawn
yeah okay this this is a reason to play
staffer in this you got this line
um because even like strong players if
you're not familiar with it
it's so easy to stumble into this as
white
um
[Music]
yeah bishop g4 is the best move
engine will give
something like minus two here in black's
favor
i'm slightly disappointed white didn't
take with pawn because that's an even
more fun line
i have covered this line
a good number of times uh
in various videos on youtube
i assume i can take
i mean there's this move this move
d4
[Music]
requires some calculation what would
happen if you became a gm
how will anybody know your rose and
without you saying i am rosen yeah it's
i don't know
hopefully someday we'll
find out
i shouldn't burn too much time here
and queen g6 i think is a move i have to
play
it's still playable for white
if this i think i get away with taking
taking
rook h1
i assume that's got to be working
oh queen h2 is made in that line
yeah d4 it takes takes when it's two
mates
um
and it takes here
[Music]
wow
[Music]
okay so i might as well take and bishop
h3 coming also threatening maiden one
also threatening the rook
and now if takes i have cast in queen
sign
okay this should be a relatively
straightforward win
but i don't want to count my eggs before
they hatch
that's a
move uh
bishop g4 looks crafty
there's e5
e5 bishop f3 what's this line
that's a funny line
it doesn't look right but it looks funny
i don't think i can resist
everything's hanging
so both of my bishops are hanging
and after e5 i'll leave my queen hanging
but the point is okay i'm threatening
mate so neither bishop can be taken
e5 bishop f3 then it's really hard to
stop breaking h1
and then another funny line queen g2
i've g6
pinning the queen of queen g6 for h1's
mate let's go
i don't think white can stop
mate
it's already just forced
the rook bishop combo is too powerful
it was a funny finish
maybe stafford gambit is just too
powerful
[Music]
i guess this is some
uh what am i trying to say
i can't think of the word
oh look at this move queen g6
or queen g3
double pin
so this queen is pinned in two
directions pinned to the king obviously
but also pinned with h1 square
this is also pinned
okay that was a nice game
yeah opponent just kind of it's very
easy to either stumble into this one
where you play h3 here
or play h3 first
and then after this this it's a it's a
transposition
um
i've covered this a bunch of times but
uh
the cool variation is after takes takes
uh blocks already threatening force mate
with queen e5 so d3 y can't stop mate if
g3 this is mate because this pawn is
pinned
so
the attempt for white to not get mated
is to play g3
win e5 threatening maiden one and then
king g2
but this is winning
after another p sacrifice for black
bishop takes f2
um
yeah it's super beautiful if rook here
then
what's the line
queen here
and there's no no good way to stop the
queen checks
rook f4 there's check here
black is winning
and if king takes and this is a fun one
check here check here
and it's also winning
despite black being down two pieces
oh another game another game
the standings oh hicaro is no longer
perfect but
he's still tied for first
okay
opponent from russia
gamma time
[Music]
nice stalemate
oh thank you tree branching
oh that's not a common move
actually wondering
i mean i want to stick in the realm of
stafford i'm hoping we just transpose
bishop c5 is probably not objectively
the best move
yeah bishop before is incredibly rare
ninth sub month so actually it's one
more month for twitch baby m rose and
pog
oh thanks baby
smurf killer baby
man i'm confused here because usually
there's a knight on c3 but
i think i'll just go for the stafford
style attack
if queen f3 has 95
and the threat is queen h4
um
i am considering actually queen h4
that's probably no good though
it looks kind of interesting
i should play 95.
so this move attacks and defends
i'll play queen h4 i mean there's also
this move wait am i winning material
bishop g4
you're just looking at bishop seven but
the king of seven the problem is there's
no f3 for white the queen is attacked
and the queen's the only thing defending
the bishop
um and here i can
yeah i can just take and
that worked out
now do i have this move
do i eat the icing on the cake
it looks like tasty icing i think i'll
just calculate for next minute
or next 30 seconds because this might
just be completely winning uh knight f3
takes takes the threat is queen g5
queen e3 doesn't help
d3 or d4 would be the temps but then
after queen h4
i don't think there's any stopping queen
g4
yeah white's pretty
defenseless
wow
that's a cool idea
i just ran the
the mate and
yeah the rooks the rook and queen are
just boxed in
bishops just dominate everything
yeah d4 controls g5 but after this
uh
kind of hard to stop queen g4
h3 i take
that was a funny game
12 move stafford win let's go
there's a line that i haven't really
looked into before
that's the thing about the stafford is
there's a lot of like nice initiative
that can come
kind of unexpectedly
and honestly when i played 95 it took me
a moment to realize that it's just
winning after bishop g4
but this is a second staffer game where
i won within
and i wanted miniature fashion
it doesn't happen too often against
title players but
when it does it's
a nice way of enjoying life